please pay no attention to the floral
patterned chair that's right behind me I
know it's very girly but for some reason
my my wife put that thing in my office
and I don't know why but I've learned
I'm not supposed to move any furniture
in this house because I don't it's it's
it's it's all been put in a place for a
reason I don't know what the reason is
but there is a method behind it and so I
can't I can't interfere with that
process all right let me tell you why
I'm doing this podcast or this this
episode of the of the podcast anyway a
few weeks ago I did a show about young
Earth Creationism and I explained why I
am NOT a young earth creationist I do
not believe that the earth is 6,000
years old I believe I believe that the
Bible is the inerrant Word of God I
believe that the bible does teach truth
but i don't believe that the bible
requires us to hold the six-day
creationist view i believe that that
view is not only scientifically wrong
but I also think it's theologically
wrong my thinking I think it is a
misinterpretation of miss reading a
misunderstanding of the text now that's
my that's my position it's very
important for you to understand that's
what my position is my position is not
that the Bible is wrong my position is
that if you read the Bible that way then
I think that you're wrong
I don't think you're a bad person I
don't think you're stupid I don't think
you're a bad Christian I just think that
you know we have a disagreement on on
that topic so there was a lot of
reaction to that episode some of it was
thoughtful and interesting and this was
a few weeks is probably almost about a
month ago that I did that episode and
you know the reaction has not because
hardly slowed down and and as I said
some of the you know heard from a lot of
people a lot of people that agree with
me and some of whom are afraid to say
out loud that they agree because they're
afraid that they'll be I don't know
disowned by their by their families if
they come out as a as an Old Earth
heretic but some of the
responses I've gotten a lot of the
responses have been disappointing to be
honest I say disappointing not because
people agreed with me I'm used to that
but disappointing because a great many
Christians made it clear that they were
simply unwilling to listen to anyone who
would dare disagree with the young-earth
view they said I'm a heretic I'm a fake
Christian and I'm a fraud I'm an idiot
I'm terrible theology I need to stop
talking about these things how dare I
I know nothing about science I don't
nothing about anything so on and so
forth
Ken Ham over at Answers in Genesis
issued a response as well Ken Ham is if
you aren't familiar Ken Ham probably the
most well known young earth creationist
in the country he runs the Creation
Museum where you can learn about how
dinosaurs and people coexisted and other
interesting facts at first you know at
first when I read his his response I
wasn't going to issue any further
rebuttal to it but he's so
mischaracterized my view and he
represented it so falsely and he made
such a strawman of what I said that on
top of my readers and listeners you know
being ticked off at me for my position
on this I've been getting emails and
messages from his followers for weeks
accusing me of saying things I never
said and taking positions I never took
all because Ken Ham told them that's
what I said for some reason a lot of
people have come under the impression
that Ken Ham is an expert on science and
theology and they trust him implicitly
on those subjects and apparently on on
every subject because when he responded
to me and blatantly misconstrued my
opinions they just went with it they
just assumed now of course he responded
to me he didn't offer a link to what I
had shown so that's that's problem
number one before I get into his
response he responded without without
without I don't think he quoted anything
that I said and he offered no link to it
whatsoever didn't he didn't he didn't so
he just it was just his he just expected
people to trust hit take his word for it
for you know he was going to represent
what I said and you're supposed to take
his word for it
and a lot of his followers did exactly
that and so because km has done this
because he attacked my faith rather than
simply rebutting my opinions he attacked
my faith so I have no choice then but to
respond and to clarify some things now
just to review my basic contention to
summarize it very briefly before getting
in the hams response I agree with the
vast majority of scientists Christian
and secular scientists alike who say
that the earth is about 4.5 billion
years old the universe's around 14
billion years old I think an honest
evaluation of the of the geological data
the cosmological data astronomical data
anthropological archeological
mathematical data all of that supports
this view the young earth view can only
cherry-pick a few bits of data from each
of these disciplines while rejecting
most of the rest of it and and that that
just isn't how you do science in other
words you can't reject almost everything
that say archaeologists and
anthropologists have discovered while
hanging your hat on a cave painting of a
dinosaur in Utah which is which is you
know I'm not that's not a straw man
that's a lot of people send me this
stuff about cave paintings of dinosaurs
they think that this is really good
evidence of a young earth you know
problem is first of all these dinosaur
cave paintings are not actually
dinosaurs and that's really clear when
you when you look at the undoctored
photo of them and for some of these
photos people were sending me I had to
go look it up myself because the photos
they were sending had been enhanced not
by the person's I think the person
sending it didn't realize that these
were doctored enhanced photos but when
you go and look at the real image it's
it's you know the the dinosaur outline
isn't isn't nearly as clear but the main
point is how can you latch on to that
while rejecting every single artifact
all of the thousands of artifacts
discovered which have been dated back
well over 10,000 years you see it
doesn't mix it
I mentioned in the in the in the first
video I did I mean there are many
examples of human artifacts that have
been dated back well over ten thousand
years just one example one type of
example are these Venus sculptures
sculptures of usually rather plump women
with exaggerated features and it's it's
believed that these were represented
fertility cults in ancient times many of
these Venus sculptures have been dated
back tens of thousands of years so the
problem is when archaeologists discover
those kinds of things it doesn't make
sense to go no that's not real no that's
not real no you're wrong about that
you're wrong about that no archaeologist
you're wrong on that you're wrong on
that no no no no yes yes that that yes
yes you're right on that one that one
right there yes the cave painting yes
that that you're right oh no all that
you're wrong but yes that you're right
about because that proves my
preconceived notions that's not an
intellectually honest way of doing
things
especially because with the cave
paintings let's say I agreed that it's a
cave painting of a dinosaur but then
let's say I argue that okay it's a cave
painting of a dinosaur but you know I
think that someone drew it 50 years ago
after dinosaur bones have been
discovered and then you say no well
that's a painting that dates back 2,000
years before dinosaurs had been
discovered which must mean the dinosaurs
existed and we're walking around back
then well how do you know that it dates
back 2,000 years because you're drought
you're trusting the dating of scientists
but then you dismiss they're dating on
almost everything else so so so they
don't know how to date anything except
the one thing that proves your theory I
mean do you see the problem with that
approach I think there's a problem with
that approach I'm not saying that we
have to accept everything that
scientists tell us but if if we're
combing through the scientific data
furiously and then oh and then accepting
implicitly as Dogma only the little bits
of things that support what we already
thought ahead of time that's just not a
that's just on an intellectually honest
way of going about it now as far as the
theological premise
there as far as the the theology of this
whole thing I argued a few things I just
want to restate what I argued number one
nobody takes the whole Bible literally
I'm gonna get more into that a little
bit later but just so we'll well-well
dog-ear that one and come back to it
number two a person can read the Genesis
story as non-literal without throwing
out the whole Bible and while still
affirming the inerrant truth of the
Bible in other words yes we could say
Genesis is true and what it says but
then the question is what does it say so
that's the debate the debate is not
whether or not it's true the debate is
what is what is it trying to actually
convey and that's where the discussion
lies the third third theological thing
the 24-hour creation day interpretation
well this doesn't even really feel a lot
Ulysses back to scientific the 24-hour
creation day interpretation isn't the
most literal interpretation a day
literally is when the earth makes one
full rotation on its axis as I argued
there is nothing nothing in the text
which suggests at least through the
first three days of creation that the
earth was rotating on a 24-hour schedule
there is no reason to think that in fact
on the first day of creation were told
that the earth is shapeless well where
is the axis on a shapeless thing and
even if the shapeless void does have an
axis somehow there's no reason to assume
that it's rotating on our current
schedule the Bible speaks of evening and
morning before there's even a Sun and I
know people say well it says evening
morning
case closed 24 hours how is that case
closed
there wasn't a Sun for the first three
mornings do you know what a morning
without a Sun looks like do you can you
draw me a picture of it because I I have
no idea what a morning when before a Sun
even looks like or what that consists of
so what that tells us is that this is
obvious when it says evening a morning
this is a different kind of evening and
more it's not the evening and
morning you're thinking of because that
evening and morning is dependent
entirely on the Sun so it's a different
kind of evening and morning which which
I think would show us that it's also a
different sort of day that we're talking
about so the point is that 24 hours is
not the literal meaning of a day the
literal meaning of a day is one full
rotation on the axis there is no reason
to think that the earth was on that
schedule before outer space and the
solar system in the galaxy even existed
now I don't take a literal
interpretation of could the creation
story but if you do I think you're
taking the wrong literal interpretation
I think young Earth Creationism fails on
its own premise because it has the wrong
idea of what a literal day is for
theological point young earthers say
that miss is very important others say
that well the earth could not be so old
because that would mean that plants and
animals and you know plants and animals
were living and dying for millions of
years before the fall but the Bible says
that death came with the fall well
that's not what the Bible says the Bible
says that death came to humans from the
fall Romans 5:12 therefore just as sin
entered the world through one man and
death through sin and in this way death
came to all people because all sinned so
it is perfectly theologically consistent
to have a dot to have dying animals and
dying plants before the fall now I do
admit ok I do admit that it raises a
question about why God would let this
very violent process of life and death
go on for millions of years it is
strange to think about all these animals
species living and dying and many going
extinct long before humans walk the
earth it's it's a it's a weird thing to
think about in theological terms but
just because I don't understand that
just because I can't wrap my head around
it doesn't mean it isn't true and
besides the young-earth view raises an
even tougher theological question about
you know if you're saying that that
animals didn't die before the fall and
now they do die because of the fall well
why would the sin of Adam
mean that dogs and lions and elephants
and cats have to suffer and starve and
die why would God punish animals for the
sins of human being so you don't really
escape the theological difficulty by
going on earth I think you I think in
fact you end up with a with a greater
theological difficulty all right now Ken
Ham I'm going to be as thorough as I can
so I will read Hamm's post that he wrote
in response to mine and I will interject
with a counter-argument wherever I see a
need for one okay the post titled Matt
Walsh and a young earth recently the
popular Catholic political blogger Matt
Walsh made a fairly lengthy video
explaining why he has it why he why he
was not a young earth creationist and
why he thinks young earth creationists
are a stumbling block to the faith of
many people the video was filled with
straw man fallacy x' misunderstandings
and mischaracterizations of what
creationists actually believe after
watching the video I was left wondering
if he had even read any of our
literature discussing the age of the
earth let's stop right there he was
wondering if I had even read his
literature well I have I'll get to that
in a minute but why should I have read
his literature he is a person with I
believe an incorrect theological view
and he has taken it upon himself to
spend his time advancing that view as
the only correct view that doesn't make
him an expert just because someone
stands up there and or they make a
website and they call it Answers in
Genesis that does not make them an
expert on on theological interpretations
or on science so it doesn't I don't have
to consult with him before making my
before forming my opinions but but what
I found is that an awful lot of
Christians really do think that Ken Ham
is the expert on this so when I you know
when I was you know giving my opinion on
it I mean probably I don't think it's
exaggerated hundreds of people were
saying well you got what
you have to go the Creation Museum well
yeah you haven't even looked at Answers
in Genesis well listen to Ken Ham on
this can't Hamilton now as it happens I
have read his literature and frankly I
find it to be extremely misleading and I
want to give you just one example and I
think because a lot of people think that
you know a lot of people as I said trust
Ken Ham and his organization they trust
it implicitly and I think they should
have some more little bit more
skepticism I want to give you just one
example to show you you know to show you
the problem with the way that Answers in
Genesis goes about things there's an
article on the site on Ken Ham site
dealing with the problem of population
okay so it seeks to answer the the the
objection that if the earth is only six
thousand years old how did we reach
seven billion people already right now I
actually don't think that that's a very
compelling argument against the young
earth view because population rates vary
so much and they're so dependent on
other factors so really who knows how
many people we would have or should have
if the earth was six thousand years old
but I was curious as to how a eiji
answers this problem and so I found an
article on the subject titled billions
of people in thousands of years now I'm
really read the first few sentences of
this article it says creationists are
often asked ask how is it possible for
the Earth's population to reach 6.5
billion people if the world is only
about six thousand years old and if
there were just two humans in the
beginning here is what a little bit of
simple arithmetic shows us let us start
in the beginning with one male and one
female
now let us assume that they marry and
have children and their children marry
and have children and so on here's the
important part here's what it says let
us assume that the population doubles
every 150 years therefore after 150
years there will be four people after
another 150 years there will be eight
after another 150 years there'll be
sixteen people and so on and so forth so
on it should be noted that this growth
rate is actually very conservative in
reality even with the
famines and natural disasters the world
population currently doubles every 40
years or so after 32 doubling which is
only four thousand eight hundred years
the world population would have reached
almost eight point six billion okay now
this is this is what Ken Ham insist we
need to read his literature before we
form our opinions okay do you see the
problem here let's assume the population
doubles every 150 years why are we
assuming that where did you get that
figure what Ken Ham I mean this figure
is on your website where did you get it
from tell me where you got it from well
I know where you got it from you just
made it up that's just a made-up figure
you made it up so that the math would
work I mean it's just it's it's it's so
dishonest this this is not an honest way
of making your point you're starting
from a completely invented premise which
was engineered so that it would lead to
the conclusion you were looking for and
there's a lot of that kind of thing and
Answers in Genesis which is why I don't
trust it as a resource arguments that
are built on false premises arguments
that start with an assumption that was
born from the original assertion so they
solve the population problem by saying
well there's 7 billion people now we
believe there were only two people to
6,000 years ago so how does the math
need to work in order to get us to our
current population number and then they
say oh well they're needing there needs
to be a doubling every 150 years and so
there was a doubling every 150 years
that's that's not that's not how math
works that's not how any of this works
that's not evidence
that's just a bald assertion that is
being put forward as an actual [ __ ] so
yes Ken I've read your literature I find
it very problematic ken goes on Walsh's
main points were that the days in
Genesis could not be 24 hours and that
science has proved that the earth is
billions of years old stop that's not
true I didn't say that the days could
not be 24 hours I said that they need
not be and they probably weren't this is
important because I'm not claiming that
God couldn't have made the earth in six
days I'm just saying that in all
likelihood looking at the science and
reading the text it seems like God
didn't make the earth in six days he
could have made it in any amount of time
he wanted to the question is what did he
do not what could he do
ken goes on we have repeatedly addressed
these claims on our website again making
me wonder if he did any research before
making his video stop there he goes
again putting forth his organization as
an authority on the subject I did plenty
of research ken I just don't trust the
information you provide for reasons I've
already explained and by the way what
credentials do you have you claim to be
an expert on apparently dozens of areas
of science I mean you must be an expert
on those areas if you can claim that the
scientific consensus in all of those
areas is wrong I mean to make a
statement like that you you must really
really know your stuff you must be
credentialed and and and and everything
and also you keep insisting that we use
you as a reference so you must be an
expert but how so I mean I looked up
Ken's bio it says he has a bachelor's in
applied science and a diploma in
education he runs the Creation Museum he
goes on speaking tours he Rhodes books
but I'm just looking for the part that
makes him an authority on any scientific
subject or theological subject
whatsoever now here's the thing I admit
that I am no expert I admit that I've
said that all along I also admit that I
could be wrong about the age of the
earth and the age of the universe I
admit that it's Ken Ham who puts himself
forward as a reference it's Ken Ham who
claims to know better than the vast
majority of scientists in every field
it's Ken Ham who claims that he
absolutely could not be wrong it's Ken
Ham who says that his interpretation of
the Bible is the only correct
interpretation so I asked on what basis
where did you gain this authority what
are you
credentials it seems that his
credentials are not much better than
mine yet only one of us insists that we
should be a reference on these subjects
Ken Ham continues however the
fundamental point that mr. Walsh is
making is that he is more willing to
rely on man's fallible word than to
trust God's infallible word
let's stop again I mean I just I can't
even make it a sentence without him
without him
blatantly mischaracterizing and again
remember he does this without providing
a link to what I actually said now what
he just said there is simply a lie I
said no such thing I said no such thing
and it is this line
it's that sentence I think in particular
that has mislead a lot of people about
my point and has caused people to assume
that I reject the Bible and that I don't
think that the Bible is infallible this
is what I've been hearing from people
that I people think that I said that the
Bible is not infallible I did not say
that but that's the way Ken Ham
presented it I'm calling on Ken to do
the honorable thing and apologize for
this for this for what he knows to be a
mischaracterization that is the
honorable and Christian thing Ken you
need to apologize and put something on
your website admitting that you
mischaracterized me I never once made
the fundamental point that we shouldn't
trust God's Word I trust God's words
entirely I just don't trust your
interpretation of that word ken it is
you I disagree with not God are you God
let me ask you are you God because if
you're not then stop saying that I
disagree with God because I disagree
with you the arrogance of such a
statement is mind-boggling I mean it's
dizzying to me I disagree with your
interpretation of God's Word I do not
disagree with God's Word I disagree with
your interpretation of God's Word
have I said it clear enough now
ken goes on he repeatedly cites science
as the reason the earth cannot be young
yet when observational science is
performed there are mountains of
evidence from geology astronomy physics
archeology and so on that the earth is
indeed young now he asserts that there
are mountains of evidence he provides no
evidence so we'll just move on ken says
by accepting the dogma of secular
science walsh completely ignores the
context of god's infallible word no ken
i completely ignore your bad science i
don't ignore God's Word and the Old
Earth view is not secular science that's
not secular science there are great many
Christians and Christian scientists who
reject the young earth view ken goes on
his claim that the day in Genesis cannot
be 24 hours because a day is defined by
the earth revolving around the Sun and
spinning on its axis reveals a
fundamental misunderstanding of what a
day is though he's correct to say that
the Sun according to Scripture wasn't
there until the 4th day
the length of the day has nothing to do
with the Sun is entirely dependent on
the rotation of the earth that's my
point Ken and people will be able to see
that if you link to what I actually said
I'm saying that a day is the Earth's
rotation I'm saying that that's my point
you have no proof and no reason to
believe that the earth was rotating on a
24-hour schedule at the beginning of
creation that's my point that's the
point I am making did you even listen to
the podcast before you responded to it I
mean you obviously don't want your
followers to listen to it before they
read your response but did you even
listen to it also to say that a day has
nothing to do with the Sun whatsoever is
obviously ridiculous I mean the the the
the parameters of a day are not
completely dependent on the Sun but
clearly if you lived on a planet that
was careening through space and not
revolving around any star at all how
would you know when a day begins you
wouldn't so obviously the concept of a
cannot be completely divorced from the
Sun ken goes on by accepting secular
interpretations of the past walsh
completely ignores what a day means in
scripture well there he goes again he
keeps doing this it's not honest it's
not right he's telling his followers
that any scientific theory that
contradicts his own must be secular as
in godless as in contrary to the word he
knows this isn't true
he knows it he knows that a great many
Christian god-fearing people to include
scientists do not accept the young earth
position there are Christians on both
sides of this issue good Christians ok I
admit that I've said that from the
beginning I was very clear about that
that I am NOT questioning the faith of
anyone who disagrees with me on this at
all I'm not questioning their their
sincerity I'm not questioning their
honesty I'm questioning ken hands
honestly because of the dishonesty that
he is engaging in here which I've
already shown you but can ham is the one
who says that only his position is
Christian in any position other than his
own is is secular this is arrogance in
the extreme he goes on walsh is right
that the word day in the bible has
multiple meanings but not when is when
it is combined with evening morning and
a number as it is in genesis every
single time it is used with those words
it means a literal 24-hour day something
he completely ignores every time the
word day is used in the same sentence
with evening morning and a number it
means 24 hours
who says who what where do you get tests
from that ken that's just an assertion
you're just restating your premise that
that's not evidence where did you get
that from he goes on it
very ironic that Walsh regularly defends
biblical positions such as biblical
marriage human life made in God's image
beginning and fertilization to created
genders and so on but rejects the
foundation for those beliefs without
appealing to Genesis there is no
foundation for marriage abortion becomes
perfectly acceptable if we aren't made
in the image of God get rid of spare
cats or spare kids what's the difference
why should we have two genders if God
did not make the male and female in the
beginning genesis provides the answers
to those questions here we have more
blatant mischaracterizations from Ken
Ham hopefully now you understand why I
why I needed to respond to this how in
the world am i forfeiting the sanctity
of life and of marriage by arguing that
the earth is not 6,000 years old how are
those things even related so if the
earth is really 4.5 billion years old
life isn't sacred what what are you
talking about when did I ever say that
God didn't make the male and female I
never said that that is not a position I
took and Ken Ham knows that when did I
say that God didn't make man in His
image I didn't say that and Ken him
knows that I didn't say that again
my point is that he is wrong about his
interpretation of day in Genesis that
has no bearing on anything else that he
just mentioned he says Walsh did not
mention it but I wonder what he makes of
how Jesus affirmed that Genesis was the
beginning in mark 10:6
or how he feels about Exodus 20:11 which
tells us everything was made in six
literal days see this is the problem
with trying to fit billions of years
into Genesis it always ends up
compromising the Bible in places outside
of Genesis 2 so either we accept the
whole Bible naturally as it is written
or we reject the whole thing trying to
fit the Bible with the secular timeline
just does not work here at Answers in
Genesis we are committed to answering
the questions posed by secularists and
compromised Christians
what the Bible says we have a lot of
articles on these topics some of which
are listed below so I am a compromised
Christian according to Ken Ham no Ken
you are lying and you know it and again
you need to apologize because to
misrepresent one of your brothers in
Christ so you know for your own selfish
reasons is is shameful now going to the
points that he made there he says that
that Jesus you know we need to accept
the six-day creation idea because of
what Jesus says it says in mark well in
mark Jesus simply restates that God made
them male and female which again I don't
dispute so that's got nothing to do with
anything in Exodus we just get a
restating of 6 days so that it does not
specify six literal days it just
restates what it said an accident in
Genesis so once again Ken Ham is
misleading us those verses do nothing at
all to enhance his point nothing
ken says the whole Bible must be taken
naturally as it is written well I agree
but the dispute over what is what
naturally as it is written means you
know that's the dispute the dispute is
how was it written what is it trying to
convey what is the natural
interpretation of this verse that's the
whole point that's the discussion was
Genesis written as a literal
documentation or as a more metaphorical
and theological work I say the latter
and I think that that is the natural
interpretation and I think that Ken Ham
has the unnatural interpretation I think
that he is infusing an unnatural
interpretation into the text but if ken
believes that the whole Bible must be
taken literally then I've got some
verses for him first Chronicles
16:30 he has fixed the earth firm
immovable well we know that the earth
moves in every since the plates move the
surface moves the earth itself moves
orbits rotates does ken take that verse
literally if he doesn't why is it okay
for him to take that metaphorically but
I can't take day metaphorically how did
he determine that it's okay to take that
metaphorically but not this
metaphorically Psalm 104 five thou did
us fix the earth on its foundation so
that it can never be shaken again is
that literal the earth shakes all the
time if ken doesn't take that literally
why do I have to take day literally
Matthew 16 and I tell you that you are
Peter and on this rock I will build my
church and the gates of Hades will not
overcome it I will give you the keys of
the kingdom of heaven whatever you bind
on earth will be bound in heaven
whatever you loose on earth will be
loosed in heaven those ten just can't
take any of that literally was Peter an
actual rock was he given a physical key
that would open literal doors to heaven
John 654 whoever eats my flesh and
drinks my blood has eternal life and I
will raise them up at the last day Luke
22 and he took bread gave thanks and
broke it and gave it to them saying this
is my body given for you do this in
remembrance of me now I know that ken is
not Catholic but here Jesus says this is
my body
straightforward statement what does the
word is mean now as Bill Clinton's
question depends on it depends on what
the definition of is is what we know
what the definition of is is don't we
this is my body whoever eats my flesh
has eternal life do this remembrance of
me these are the direct words of Christ
but ken takes them metaphorically
how does he justify that I mean that
doesn't seem to me to be the natural
interpretation of the text that is not
interpreting the text as it is written
Jesus does not say this is like my body
says this is my body
that's what
it's just what he says right so how can
can take these words metaphorically
while telling me that I can't take de
metaphorically Matthew 24:34 after
talking about the end times
Jesus says truly I tell you this
generation will not pass away until all
of these things have happened
what is the naturally as it is written
interpretation of that first generation
is a very simple word isn't it
it would seem anyway I mean generation
is a simple straightforward word so why
get all fancy you with interpreting
generation means all of the people that
were born at a particular time right so
when someone says to a group these
things will happen during this
generation he means soon as in you folks
are gonna see it go down right and
that's the interpretation that the very
early Christians had if you know
anything about about the first century
of the church you know that a great many
Christians thought that the early the
world was going to end imminently in
their lifetimes but of course it didn't
so we now understand that this
generation must be understood
differently a simple word like
generation becomes not so simple anymore
right and so there's been a debate for
centuries about what generation means in
this context does Ken Ham insist on the
most literal and strictest
interpretation of that of that word
generation if not then why does he
insist on it for day I mean you know it
really starts to seem like ken doesn't
take the Bible literally at all but he
only takes certain parts of it literally
and then he insists that everyone must
take those parts literally - or else
they haven't forfeited the entire faith
you know it really seems like Ken Ham
has on his own authority gone through
the Bible and found certain statements
that would appear to be literal
statements and said no not literal and
then other statements
that would appear to be literal and say
yes that must be literal it cannot be
anything else and he has declared that
that his determination is now gospel
truth well again I asked Ken who told
you that
where are you getting this from did God
tell you did you have some kind of
special revelation from God because if
not then how dare you suggest that
anyone who disagrees with you is a
compromised Christian no Ken I think
you're the compromised one engaging in
this kind of dishonesty and this level
of arrogance I remind everyone again
that I never questioned to the faith of
those who disagree with me I did say
that I think the young earth view when
it is advanced is a is a puts an
obstacle and looking the way of
non-believers an unnecessary obstacle
and I think that's just simply the case
I mean talk to talk to them and they'll
one of the first things I'll tell you is
look I just can't I know that the earth
is more than six thousand years old if
you're telling you that I have to
believe that in order to be a Christian
then I can't be a Christian so I do
think that's the case but I know I don't
question the integrity the sincerity the
good hardness the the you know anything
I don't question anything about abouts
people that hold that view I think this
is a discussion that we can have and I
also don't pretend to know exactly how
old the universe or the earth is I don't
know that I mean that's that that
question is way above my pay grade but
Ken Ham thinks it's not above his he
knows everything but but I I don't know
everything I and I admit that but I'm
just not going to have someone
misrepresent me in that way and I think
that if you're a follower of Ken Ham
that you should know that this is how he
operates and and then
you should decide how seriously you're
gonna take him from then on from then on
out it's really disappointing you know
it's it's a sad thing that I had to
address this publicly I even waited a
month hoping that he would you know
maybe have a change of heart and
backtrack and admit that he miscarried
but he didn't so so so here we are all
right we'll leave it there thanks
everybody for listening thanks for
watching have a it is Friday right yeah
so have a great weekend Godspeed